- And you have people
out there saying, listen,
I want my representatives
to go to Washington
and repeal Obamacare,
but I want them to keep
the Affordable Care Act.
(audience laughing)
Where do you go from there?
And that, you get to a
situation where we combine this
immense amount of
cynicism with this immense
amount of ignorance, you can do anything.
You can accomplish almost anything.
You tell people the moon's
made of green cheese.
I mean, we're almost there, right?
We're back to a flat earth society.
We have people on the Internet, you know,
going back to, that the
moon landing was fake.
It shouldn't surprise
us that that's possible.
And when all of those
things become possible,
and people have almost
no political literacy,
you cannot sustain the practices
that sustain a democratic republic.